or what did I haven't read any papers
for at least a month yeah thatthat's at
once two things one of the dumbest moves
I've ever heard of being made by a
network and also it's what I knew when I
first heard about it went back when they
were telling jay although your ratings
are great we don't need you to forever
so you know a wonderful way to treat the
psyche of the performer which is one
thing that we're people never have a
clue about and I knew when I first heard
it this is never going to work I don't
know how exactly I don't pretend to know
why ten o'clock proved to be such an
awful time for a talk show but it is the
psychology of lat that much later when
the tonight show's on and people have
had a drink or two and about to go to
bed and what some entertainment before
nodding off is very different from how
you feel at ten o'clock when you could
see law and order or another such shows
and and it just unnatural to Dover to
the mess Jay inherited I thought Conan
was what interesting when he pointed out
that that that that hijack offer they
offered him that cynical thing that no
one in his right mind would accept to
get rid of him when he said that you can
have the tonight show at 1205 well
somebody's including Conan pointed out
that 1205 is no longer tonight that's
tomorrow so would we have to be called
the early early show but anything but
that's a night show and I managed I
think too damaged to make somewhat
damaged goods and both artists involved
and they also succeeded in making their
enemy David Letterman NBC's competition
more successful than ever so whoever is
responsible for this boat
move well as we know from watching these
things certainly within a week or two be
promoted and given a big raise